unser zuschauer wolf christian stolle
aus hamburg hat probleme mit rammstein
tickets da schauen wir mal rein ins
video
ich habe probleme mit der firma event
irgend mit einem rammstein vip-ticket
die tournee von rammstein es verschoben
worden
auf unbestimmte zeit ich möchte jetzt
einfach nur mein geld zurück hat
versucht mir die eventim in kontakt zu
treten hat alles nicht geklappt ich habe
versucht schriftlich oder telefonisch
aber eine kontaktaufnahme ist leider
nicht möglich ich möchte jetzt nur noch
mein geld zurück bitte hilf mir dabei
müssen wir einst vorausschicken
natürlich melden sich sehr viele
zuschauer und sagen ich habe ärger mit
eventim aber an kennt konzern nochmal
einordnen nicht immer oder in vielen
fällen ist eventim letztlich nicht
verantwortlich weil ich mein ticket
natürlich über eventim gekauft habe aber
eventim ist nicht mein vertragspartner
das heißt also diese wut die ich auch
durchaus verstehen kann dass klar
dann steigt ja auch keiner durch wer ist
da mein vertragspartner habe ich
überhaupt das kleingedruckte verstanden
oder auch gelesen
das ist wirklich kompliziert aber
trotzdem müssen wir das von vornherein
sagen eventim ist nicht der
vertragspartner das heißt mein geld
müsste ich eigentlich vom veranstalter
wieder bekommen wenn ich dann unter eine
härtefallklausel fallen
normalerweise gibt es einen gutschein an
chemnitz hat die ganzen fakten genau so
ist das es ist ja diese gutscheinlösung
ist er verabschiedet worden das heißt
derjenige der dieses konzert eben jetzt
nicht besuchen kann bekommt erstmal
gutschein der ist gültig bis ende 2021
und eben nur wenn das persönlich
unzumutbar ist dann bekommt man sein
geld zurück das können persönliche
gründe seien beispielsweise finanzielle
gründe
das kann aber auch beispielsweise der
grund sein dass sich auf einer
urlaubsreise ein konzert besuchen wollte
und jetzt diese urlaubsreise natürlich
nicht wiederhole im nächsten jahr
ich meine jetzt da dies ja auch
ausgefallen aber im nächsten jahr möchte
ist eben anders machen dann ist wohl
dieser verweis so steht es ausdrücklich
in der gesetzesvorlage und zumutbar das
heißt dass ich dann trotzdem mein geld
zurückbekomme und dieser erste
diese probleme was jetzt alle haben ist
im grunde genommen dieses verbrauch
abhängt ich melde mich also beim einer
gesellschaft die mir das ticket
vermittelt hat und die sagt wende dich
doch bitte an den veranstalter und der
veranstalter sagt jetzt wiederum wenn du
dich an jemand anders und das ist
wirklich ärgerlich
mein vertragspartner ist fast immer
derjenige der auf dem ticket steht oder
an den sollte mich auch wenden
und wenn ich jetzt ein klageverfahren
einleiten muss beispielsweise dann ist
auch immer der veranstalter meinen
anspruchsgegner genau das können zum
teil sehr kleine firmen seien vielleicht
auch ein mann betriebe und das könnte
möglicherweise zu problemen führen aber
tatsächlich müssen wir das sagen wir
lesen das wirklich in sehr vielen
zuschriften
ich habe ärger mit eventim ich fühle
mich abgezockt von event in den meisten
fällen ist eventim nicht schuld dass man
hier an dieser stelle ganz klar sagen